es gab zeiten da war sie fast
allgegenwärtig
die musikkassette heute gehört sie zu
den aussterbenden tonträgern
der autor und journalist wie andres weiß
wo immer noch kassetten verkauft werden
zb im plattengeschäft stahlplatte berlin
hier gibt es kassetten mit musik aus
aller welt
jan drees lässt in seinem buch
kassettendeck soundtrack einer
generation viele musiker und künstler
ihre ganz persönlichen kassetten
geschichten erzählen
das absolut faszinierende einer kassette
war doch dass auf einmal leute ihr
eigenes programm zusammenstellen konnten
das war broadcast yourself gebe es jetzt
von youtube kennen
in aller erster form sandra heinzelmann
ist dem tonträger aus plastik bis heute
treu geblieben
sie liegt unter dem künstlernamen smh in
berliner bars mit kassetten auf
kassetten dj-set vorzubereiten ist
aufwendig vor den auftritten spult die
dj leere kassette an die richtige stelle
um nicht vor ort zeit beim suchen der
songs zu verlieren
man muss halt durch die musik blättern
so wie früher cd laden oder platten ein
und nimmt eben das ding raus den
tonträger und selbst den rhythmus
spielen und damit arbeiten deshalb bis
haptisches und es hat es macht spaß die
große deutsche funkausstellung in berlin
im jahre 1963 die niederländische firma
philips stellt die erste kassette samt
recorder vor
anfangs sich die klangqualität zwar noch
bescheiden doch durch verbesserte
technik werden auch anspruchsvolle hörer
schnell zu kassetten fans das aufnehmen
von sogenannten mixtapes mit
lieblingsliedern oft für den oder die
angebetete entwickelt sich zur eigenen
wissenschaft samt liebevoller
covergestaltung
1979 bringt die firma sony den walkman
auf den markt die kassette bestimmt
fortan das lebensgefühl einer ganzen
generation
dazu steckt in dieser kassette auf eine
demokratisierung der musik gerade im
osten wo es ist ja nur zwei große label
gab starts label am kulturfunktionäre
bestimmt wer darauf kann und auf einmal
konnten bands vorbei an der staatsraison
ihre musik aufnehmen und auch einfach
verbreiten
abseits der globalen verkaufsstrategien
der großen plattenfirmen betreibt konrad
rodenberg in berlin seinen kassetten
label froggy record in kleinstauflagen
von 20 bis 100 stück wird eigene musik
oder die befreundete bands aus aller
welt vertrieben
hier entsteht alles in hand arbeiten von
den kopien bis zur covergestaltung sie
verkaufen auch die kassetten meist
selbst zum beispiel für konzerte
ich merke auch zutage gern daran dass es
ja das ist einfach hörbar vergänglich
ist das ganze also dass das abnutzung
hörbar ist und dass dadurch einfach ein
bisschen mehr persönlichkeit kriegt
in deutschland hatte die musikkassette
ihre court jahr 1991 mit 109 millionen
verkauften exemplaren 2014 waren es nur
noch um 200.000 kassette als medium mit
ihrer aura zu erinnern bedeutet auch
sich ein stück musikgeschichte zu
erinnern ich weiß nicht ob das auch für
jedes komprimierung format gilt mit dem
wir jetzt unsere musik klein rechnen
ganz in vergessenheit geraten wird die
kassette wohl erstmal nicht zu viele
erinnerungen hängen an ihm